Making liquid way at home is so easy.
All you need is cheese cloth or like, cotton,
two Mason jars or something similar,
some stick of sorts to hang your cloth above a bowl.
This is just like a cotton scarf that I had in my closet.
Be careful without overflowing.
Fill your keeper to the top.
But in my case, I needed a finer strain.
So I doubled up on fabric to get a clear end product.
Twenty four hours later,
you're gonna have this thick cream cheese like substance.
You just add salt, herbs,
whatever you want. Store it in the fridge and use it as like,
a cream cheese spread that's super rich and probiotics.
And then the liquid that's gonna be left over in the bowl
is gonna be a liquid way. My liquid gold.